thank you
[Music]
all right so um in San Antonio this very
tragic thing happened uh some dude let
his pitbulls out of the yard on accident
and they ended up killing this 81 year
old man oh my God it's caught on video
it's pretty We're not gonna watch a
video yeah I gotta see the video after
this I gotta see it you can't just throw
that image in my head or not maybe do
you like those videos no I don't like it
I just gotta see it once you hear about
it messed me up because the version in
my head is crazy yeah and I just got to
see it wasn't as crazy as the world
like they [__] just ripped him apart
you know like the dogs are like walking
and grabbing them you know what I mean
and just [__] I mean it's it's rough
because it's like it's one of those
things where the dude's 81. so it's like
even though they haven't completely like
you know got him yet he can't do that
much okay so yeah yeah so it's that's
what's wrong certain pits are scary man
like they're big they're beautiful dogs
though that's what we're gonna talk
about today yeah they killed him so um
do you guys believe in killing all pit
bulls no 80 pound pit is a big [__]
pitch you guys have seen like they're
muscular you guys know that whole like
uh stigma or stereotype around pit bulls
and how like yeah yeah I think it's on
the owner that's the owner that's the
owner yeah you see like when you get a
pit with a good owner they're the
sweetest it's like the little rascal dog
yeah they're the best dogs man but then
you get some guys who are a little
they're not they don't want to take care
of their dog and then it's because it's
the [__] ghetto dog of choice all
over the world I don't know how the [__]
it got to Asia but Asian gangsters have
those dog yeah there's people that
yeah you know what I mean like if you're
a bad owner you can have like a like a
hell yeah
yeah because they're not trained yeah
you need Caesar Milan bro have you seen
that video of that dog like this little
Chihuahua like I think it's like a
little wiener dog I saw it this morning
he started attacking Caesar Milan and he
grabs it like this and then he like yeah
he got one bite in but he still grabbed
him yeah he's like whoa like what the
[__] happened what about the idea that
like let's say a pitbull versus a lap
dog the pit bull's practically
Unstoppable once it's going off yeah
one's a stapler and the other one's a
[__] gun yeah oh that's that's the
only thing Little Chihuahua bite your
[__] toe that's not nothing's gonna
happen what you're trying to say is we
should kill everyone that's over six
feet tall
it's a weapon that's always it starts
going there's no stopping Anthony you
just made no [__] stopping a guy with
a cute handsome [__] face that's a
weapon too dude get the guy out of the
bar take all the girls dude
sorry there's definitely like an obtuse
amount of like responsibility skewed
towards whether you want a pimple though
yeah that's like you gotta really be
like I think you got to punish the owner
that's like he said it's like buying a
gun you know what I mean but the owner
got punished right yeah but uh yeah they
look and he killed the dogs yeah well he
killed the dogs you have to yeah
after they kill humans or bite what's
the punishment for the owner really they
should kill the owner
your dog kill somebody they should kill
you yeah you won't kill this guy whoa
yeah
glasses do contacts I think have you
ever heard of Lasik I wear glasses yeah
if you're whatever you're a dog does to
someone else they gotta do that to you
yeah so if your dog licks your
neighbor's dick you gotta you gotta make
your neighbors it's only right I'm gonna
provoke the [__] and my neighbor's dog
what's up dude put peanut butter on it
yeah go for it go for it it said like in
this in the stats of it over over half
of the dog attacks that are fatal are
from pitbulls that that's what I was
gonna say so pit bulls are known to be
crazier but I think it's more
correlation though and they've been bred
were they bred for that reason certain
certain pits yeah certain pits are and
then and then there's certain people
exactly there's certain people that want
those breeding dogs like they want those
kinds of pit bulls so that it's then
it's like it's on the [__] owner it's
on them yeah no but it's scary when
pitbulls fight like I used to have a pit
bull I used to have a pit bull and uh
they're scary [__] dogs
I [__] up because I got the dog like
old yeah like it was an older he already
had some Battle Scars you know what I
mean he had like rules so I didn't he
didn't give a [__] about me I tried to
tell make him sit and he's just like man
this is the [__] did they ever just
randomly flip out
so the neighbor's dog is a pit as well
and then it made it tried it made a hole
to try to go into my yard but they would
fight by the time it would get there so
it was like every morning dude they were
just arguing I'm like dude these guys
are [__] idiots and then one morning
they're screaming and yeah and I look
and dude my dog had this other dog by
the neck I guess the dog made his way
through my yard and just was doing this
like and the dog's neck was just cool
and I'm just like and I panicked because
the guy was like dude get your dog get
your dog and like when I got there and I
saw that I'm like yeah dude in my head
I'm like he's he's gonna die just let
him die like that's what I shut down I
was like I'm not gonna do anything I'm
just like that's well that's so tough I
froze and I was like dude their dog's
dead dude I'm not gonna like that's it
like I didn't know I couldn't do it so
the guy [__] jumped the fence he's a
real man and [__] he just [__] jumped
the fence and he [__] went over there
and grabbed my dog like nothing just
looking grab them by like right here I
guess they let go if you grab them right
here on the side suppose if you lift the
rear two legs that's what I meant the
dogs like they go they go what the [__]
so he had to grab one right here dude I
don't know if you [__] is this weird
for you but you got one right here and
then you just pull them and they just
like release their jaw and then they
[__] he pushed them out and then the
other dog
damn he lived what wow he lived but
still try to dig and fight again no he
knew better you know what I mean but he
had like this swollen [__] neck dude
and I would just see the dog just
looking and then he'll drag this thing
and then over the years it got better
and better but yeah it was a it was a
weird moment that I was just did you
tell him shouldn't the trespass buddy
yeah he dug in a year but that's but
that's the thing right like 50 of dog
owners probably should not have dogs
like because they're not responsible
they keep them they [__] don't train
their dogs like they just let them roam
the streets that's right I've talked
about this on here [__] ad nauseum
about how you look at your ring camera
there's the app and you see all these
people losing their dogs constantly more
people on their phones and they're dog
[__] all over the place you see it
every single day so like already people
in their mindset with dogs is like I
don't give a [__] it's a pet whatever so
it's like if you're gonna have a dog you
can't have that mindset so it's on you
it's you are the owner so you should go
to [__] jail damn jail passionate not
for real though cause [__] that that's
crazy like you gotta be responsible go
to jail bat boy nobody want to do the
the day-to-day work of like dealing with
their dog that's what sucks man so that
means if uh kids kill people should the
parents go to jail too yup yes I think
so now we're touching now we're going
wait a minute
no that is true though it's pretty crazy
do they in any circumstance does that
ever happen blame the well it's like if
the parents uh left their guns unchecked
or something like that you know what I
mean then it's a gun owner's fault right
yeah like if a kid takes like your gun
if Tyga takes your gun yeah
talk to that [__] I know plenty
of very responsible pit owners and they
know that like their dog is aggressive
to other dogs and they say like so they
go like we just don't we they do their
due diligence of making sure that they
don't take their [__] pit to the dog
park they oh dude those are crazy videos
when people do that yeah they make sure
that they keep their dog like restrained
and they're very on top of how they get
their dog and keep them away from other
dogs walking by so it's like there's are
there are responsible pit owners but it
just idiots like this they just ruin it
for everybody yeah that's crazy but then
that's crazy that he killed it a man
that must be a sucky way to die yeah for
sure that's crazy that old you know
you're like
made it through life how many people
through [__] and you die from a dog
you made it through AIDS pandemic you
made it through the [__] cold fan you
know what I mean and then you died
through a dog yeah you made it through
World War II he made it through diabetes
dude yeah because it's Texas you get bit
in the Korean War yeah
I think like Gulf War in the video it
looks like they're just biting me these
by the time the video starts already on
the ground and they're just like biting
everything was it like a bystander just
recording yeah yeah it was just like oh
what the [__] did he say world star this
is [__] Savage dude he because it's
like they couldn't do anything about it
oh like and then there's another guy in
that situation do you think it's okay to
kill the dog like if you if you were
there and you had like a gun and and
you're just like [__] I love dogs but I
don't think this guy's gonna let go yeah
I think it's okay I mean to Save a Life
of a person getting bit Yeah I was gonna
say to me it's like when it comes to
life but he's already dead
I don't know I love dogs I love dogs but
I was I would be like but what if this
guy's been like bullying the dogs yeah
did they finally you know he was your
[__] stories get twisted yeah I like
it I like where you're going with this
he's 80. then what happened but yeah and
then what happened what if like the dogs
were just like you [__] [__]
you're [__] mean to me you know and
then you always kick me when you come
walk by me and [__] and I'm standing
there and I'm like oh okay yeah the guy
was like Hey [__] might get the [__]
out of here
one day [__] yeah and that one
day happened Justice dude see that's why
the whole guy would die on my watch
because I'm just gonna decide if I
should help the dogs or not I guess I
like that judge just painted the picture
that this old guy's a [__] [__] to
make us feel all better about it
we gotta talk about two different points
yeah he could have been you never know
we don't know the full context that's
why I always question about saving
someone's life because then if someone's
drowning I'm just like but you might be
a child predator oh yeah that's true
yeah so should you just drown
that's what you gotta ask them a bunch I
vote for you not to be mayor dude
right there who's the other guy in the
first place dude
foreign